وفي مقاطعه المواليه لروسيا اعلنت سلطات
المقاطعه عن مقتل مدني في تفجير سياره
بمدينه
وصف عضو مجلس الاداره العسكريه والمدنيه
في المقاطعه الحادث بالعمل الارهابي في
المقابل قال عمده مدينه ميلوتوبيلا
الاوكراني في مقاطعه ان السياره تخص
مسؤولا سابقا في اجهزه انفاذ القانون
الاوكرانيه قبل ان ينخرط في صفوف القوات
الروسيه وحذر عمده
من وصفهم بالمتعاونين مع الروس من نفس
المصير بحسب تعبيره
قالت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها
تصدت لمحاوله تقدم روسيه في عشره محاور
قتال باقليم دومباس شرقيه اوكرانيا وقد
نقل مراسلنا عن مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيه
باحتدام المعارك في جبهه مدينه الشماليه
مقاطعه
واعترفت المصادر بان القوات الروسيه حققت
تقدما وصفته بالطفيف عند المحور الشمالي
الشرقي والمحور الجنوبي للمدينه رغم تكبد
القوات الروسيه خسائر كبيره في الافراد
والمعدات وفقا للمصادر ذاتها
قالت تهيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان عدد من
المدنيين سقطوا قتلى وجرحى في غارات جويه
روسيه على مقاطعه خرسون وميكولايف وكرامه
نقلا عن الادارات العسكريه لتلك المناطق
بان القوات الروسيه نفذت اكثر من 100 هجوم
بالمدفعيه ما تسبب بتدمير عدد من المنازل
والبنى التحتيه المدنيه بالمقابل اكد
الجيش الاوكراني ان قوته نفذت خلال
الساعات الماضيه سلسله غارات على مواقع
لتمركز القوات الروسيه داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه